the president's former national security
adviser Michael Flynn will be sentenced
later this morning the retired general
admitted lying to the FBI about his
contacts with Russia's then US
ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac in 2016
now Flynn is one of five Trump aides who
have entered guilty pleas in the special
counsel probe now in a very unusual
tweet this morning the president wished
him good luck and said Flynn's been
under tremendous pressure Paula Reid is
outside US District Court in Washington
Paula we know that the special counsel
has praised Michael Flynn for giving
substantial assistance to the government
is that why he may not face much time in
prison exactly the expectation today is
that he may be spared any time in prison
for that substantial assistance since he
pleaded guilty about a year ago he has
met with the special counsel 19 times
he's the only person in the entire
Special Counsel investigation whom
Muller has recommended received no jail
time we don't know is exactly what he
has shared with investigators during
those interviews the only thing we know
is that he has provided evidence about
contacts between the Trump transition
team and Russia we have heard from
Flynn's team his his defense team that
he should face a LifeFlight sentence
because he was caught off guard by the
the FBI is that a fair defense by them
and explained again for everybody
exactly what Flynn is accused of doing
that's right Flynn's lawyers argue that
he was not told that lying to the FBI
was a crime but Norah the special
counsel pushed back pretty hard on that
they reminded the court this was a
voluntary interview he invited FBI
investigators to the White House and
they also point out this is a man who
had three decades in public service
often working very closely with the FBI
and he should not have had to have been
reminded that lying to the FBI is a
crime all right Paula thank you so much